le périmètre est bouclé depuis ce matin
par les forces de l'ordre à 7h30
alertés par un tiers les pompiers
arrivent dans cette maison de romenay à
l'intérieur il découvre un premier corps
celui d'hiver guérin 87 ans assassinée
il se rend alors chez son fils yves pour
le prévenir
l'homme de 52 ans qui ne vit qu'à
quelques centaines de mètres a lui aussi
été tué le suspect n est autre que son
fils clément guérin
à 25 ans le jeune homme est déjà connu
des services de police en 2016 c'est sa
mère valérie qu'il avait assassiné à
coups de couteau dans la cave du
domicile familial un crime dont il n'a
jamais eu à répondre diagnostiqué
schizophrène clément guérin avait alors
été jugé irresponsable de ses actes puis
hospitalisé jusqu'en décembre dernier
interpellé ce matin l'homme a été placé
en garde à vue